hi I'm Eric Boston adventures infinity
ward's digital release keep squeezing
out interesting Easter eggs that we
missed the first time around it's kind
of the chicken that's literally keeping
this egg eater fed day after day the
latest egg that you have all brought to
my attention is this possible reference
to Captain Marvel if you look closely a
sash worn by call obsidian a fantasy's
black order has the same colors and
design of Captain Marvel Suzumiya yes
these same colors that we saw on Nick
Fury's comm device to Carol Danvers in
the post-credits scene
so let's look closely at Co obsidian an
infinity war and discuss what his
possible connection could be to Captain
Marvel and other big reveals that could
be coming in the Captain Marvel movie
next year and real quick before I begin
this video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain a
website or online store make it with
Squarespace or details on that later
okay let's start with Kolb City and sash
he wears this throughout the movie and
the design is most visible in the fight
sequence with ebony ma Tony Stark Bruce
Banner Doctor Strange Wong and
eventually spider-man in New York in
this scene yes the sash does look red
and blue and gold leading many online to
speculate where he got that Captain
Marvel
Hot Topic might this mean that cul
obsidians origin could be associated
with the Kree one theory suggests that
co-op city might have gotten the sash
from the suit worn by Captain Marvel's
predecessor Marvel who will be played by
Jude Law and the upcoming Captain Marvel
movie in 2019 which will be an origin
story set in the 1990s Marvel was a Kree
warrior Kree were a genetically
engineered militaristic race with super
abilities and during a war between the
Korean another alien race called the
Skrull Marvel runs into Air Force pilot
Carol Danvers and passes on his powers
to her according to this theory we might
see Thanos's Black Order play a role in
this conflict and maybe call obsidian
could have been the one who killed
Marvel carrying off part of a suit and
wearing it as a kind of trophy in a very
bold fashion statement that would be a
very cool piece of backstory to see in
Captain Marvel especially since I feel
like we didn't really learn a whole lot
about the black order in Infinity Ward
but I gotta admit this flare is kind of
a weird way for a warrior to boast his
past victories like wearing the defeated
skull as a hat or tattooing their name
on your neck no regrets maybe but you
know that ain't the same thing as
wearing your defeated enemies
in a fierce French tuck and yet in case
you're not already screaming this at
your screen this sash might not even be
red and blue guys feel look closely at
the sash in other scenes and compared to
merchandise released for the movie it
definitely looks more orange and purple
or white and gold or whatever color Gani
is I think many of these scenes with
colored City probably went through color
balancing during the editing process
that could have made this sash appear to
look more red and blue but I get it
people we want to know more about Thanos
his team and how Captain Marvel could
connect to the next Avengers movie so
with those questions in mind let's
address a couple other ways Captain
Marvel could connect to the overall
Avengers storyline
first let us reexamine infinity Wars
post-credit scene when Nick Fury started
to fade away but not before making
parents cover their kids ears and
signaling someone on a weird pager
[Music]
so the implication here is that Nick
Fury is calling Captain Marvel for help
in this apocalyptic fight against Thanos
but the question then becomes why did
Nick Fury only wait until now to call
her back in the first Avengers movie why
did fury implied that the six Avengers
were humanity's last hope in the Battle
of New York against Loki in the Chitauri
army when somewhere a badass with powers
greater than Thor was just twiddling
their thumbs
maybe Fury was reluctant to make contact
with Carol Danvers maybe he was afraid
of her it has been suggested that the
Captain Marvel movie will reveal how
Nick Fury lost his eye and experience he
actually alluded to in Captain America
Winter Soldier someone I lost or perhaps
he trusted Carol Danvers and her
inability to contain her new powers left
fury scarred Captain Marvel could also
address the origins of Thanos's quest to
obtain all six Infinity stones because
remember at the start of all of this
Thanos previously possessed one of the
stones which we later learned was the
mind stone he granted Loki use of the
sceptre in order to obtain the space
stone inside the tesseract but Loki of
course failed causing panis to lose the
mine stone that the scepter contained
now we still don't really know how
Thanos got that mind stone to begin with
perhaps the kree-skrull conflict in the
Captain Marvel movie could shed some
light on that missing piece of Thanos's
history and maybe the reason a furious
summoning Carol Danvers is because she
knows how Thanos acquired his first
infinity stone which could be
information key to defeating him
honestly thanasis rise to power was one
of the more intriguing parts Infinity
Ward that I feel the movie only scratch
the surface of we saw that flashback of
him recruiting Gamora but what about the
other children of Thanos where did the
other four members of the Black Order
come from and is there anything to this
wild theory that I read about that
suggests that the four of them are the
members of the Fantastic Four
transformed into monstrous versions of
themselves chew on that and as I
mentioned before this video is brought
to you by Squarespace
if you want to set up a super stylish
website fast you can make it with
Squarespace whether it's to set up a
business or showcase some of your
creative work or post photos of you
cosplaying as Captain Marvel everyone's
doing it there's no shame Squarespace
has eight new templates in 2018 they
look so awesome and you don't have to
know anything about coding or design
they take care of all that for you
just go to Squarespace com4
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com slash new
rockstars to get 10% off your first
purchase or click on the link in the
description and comment down below with
your thoughts on all this tweet me
directly at ei vas and follow me
rockstars on Twitter for updates of our
videos like this video share it around
and subscribe the new rock stars for
deeper details that you miss from your
favorite Marvel movies thanks for
watching bye
[Music]